MY SANCTUARY
FOR ORPHAN BABY ANIMALS
IS ALMOST COMPLETE.
WILL THROW ME A BIG
GRAND OPENING PARTY?
- SURE, ETHEL,
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
- YES.
SEE, MALLOY?
IT'S NOT ABOUT MY GOOD LOOKS.
- IT'S ABOUT MY GOOD IDEAS.
- OHH, YEAH...
- OF COURSE IT IS.
- WOODY...COULD I--
- NO, [bleep] OFF!
LISTEN, PEOPLE,
NOW THAT OUR DARLING HAROLD
HAS RETIRED TO FLORIDA...
- I THOUGHT THEY LOCKED HIM UP
IN A MENTAL INSTITUTION.
- FLORIDA, MENTAL INSTITUTION--
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
ANYWAY, WE NEED A NEW RANGER
A.S.A.P.
NOW, I GOT SOME MONEY
FROM JACKUBOWSKI
TO SHOOT A RECRUITMENT VIDEO.
IT'S GOT TO BE GOOD--
LIKE, GODFATHER III GOOD.
NOT DOG SHIT
LIKE THEM FIRST TWO.
ETHEL, SINCE YOU'RE
THE ONLY PERSON HERE
WITH A SOMEWHAT
HUMAN APPEARANCE,
YOU'RE GONNA BE
MY LEAD ACTRESS.
- WOODY, DID YOU
FORGET SOMETHING?
IT'S THE FIRST OF THE MONTH.
- OH, YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
THE RANGER OF THE MONTH IS...
STEVE AGAIN.
- YAY.
- NOW, IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME,
I HAVE TO GO TO MY OFFICE
FOR AN IMPORTANT MEETING.
- AND I HAVE TO CALL MY MOM
AND TELL HER THE GOOD NEWS.
[melodic ringtone]
HEY...
I KNOW THAT RINGTONE.
HI, MOM.
MOM!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- HI, HONEY.